تحذيرا لمن تصفهم بيجين بالانفصاليين يجري
الجيش الصيني تدريبات عسكريه لمده ثلاثه
ايام في مضيق تايوان تقول الصين ان
المناورات رد على تواطئ مع قوى خارجيه
وتركز التدريبات على القدره على السيطره
على البحر والجو والاعلام في سيناريو
تطويق كامل للجزيره
وشهدت في محيط تايوان سفن عسكريه صينيه
وطائرات المقاتله تحلق بالقرب من اجوائها
واقتربت احدى السفن الصينيه من جزيره
بنجتان التي تقع على بعد 126 كيلومترا عن
تايوان من جهتها افادت وزاره الدفاع
التايوانيه بتعقب اثنتين واربعين طائره
عسكريه صينيه في محيط الجزيره وقالت انها
رصدت 29 مقاتله اخترقت خط المنتصف في
المضيق فيما وصفته بزعزعه الامن
والاستقرار وتعريض المنطقه للخطر موضحه
انها ارسلت طائرات وسفن حربيه واستخدمت
منظومات صواريخ ارضيه لمراقبه طائرات
الجيش الصيني تطورات تاتي اياما بعد عوده
رئيسه تايوان سانغوين من زياره للولايات
المتحده التقت خلالها رئيس مجلس النواب
كيفن ماكارتي وهي خطوه اثارت غضبا صينيا
كما تتزامن المناورات الصينيه مع استقبال
رئيسه تايوان وفدا من المشرعين الامريكيين
يقوده مايكل ماكول رئيس لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه بمجلس النواب خلال اللقاء اكدما
واشنطن لتقديم الدعم للجزيره وهو ما ردت
عليه سانغو بان تتطلع الى مزيد من تعزيز
التعاون الامني مع الولايات المتحده
وطالما كانت تقارب بين واشنطن نذيرا
بزياده منسوب التوتر في مضيق تايوان ففي
عام 95 من القرن الماضي واحتجاجا على
زياره الرئيس التايواني
انذاكوي الى الولايات المتحده اعلنت الصين
تجارب اطلاق صواريخ في المياه المحيطه
بتايوان وفي السنه الماضيه زارت رئيسه
مجلس النواب الامريكي ناسيبي لوسي تايوان
ثم توالت بعد ذلك لقاءات المسؤولين
التايوانيين والمشرعين الامريكيين فردت
الصين بالاعلان عن اكبر مناورات جويه
وبحريه وفي الوقت الذي تحتفظ فيه واشنطن
بسياسه الغموض الاستراتيجيه تبدو بجين
اكثر صراحه في فعلها ورد فعلها في مساله
تايوان